I feel like we're at this cusp of
something very strange happening.
Like we're in the middle of it right now,
but we're at the cusp of something very
strange where all would take is one
massive world event,
one Matt to to completely remap how we
view each other and how we view things.
It's very disconcerting to me.
This feels like without
that one big world event,
we're not that far away
from them right now.
There are parallel universes right now
the exist on things that you were thought
everyone can accept as a basic
facts. Like what you know, um,
uh, I mean Syria. Yeah, the
white helmets that there,
there are some fairly serious people
saying the white helmets are, you know,
some kind of media front
for alk hydro on those.
Would you explain the White Helmets
for people? So when there's a,
when there's a bombing
and a building collapses,
they go in and drag people out and
get them medical attention as quick as
possible.
And people think that there somehow or
another involved in it through our front,
yeah. To to, and the,
the footage is faked in order to drum
up sympathy for the rebel held areas.
I mean, that's, I've, I've
heard, you know, serious people
say that. Serious people.
Yeah. Not, not, not loons on
Facebook. I've heard, you know,
journalists. Yeah, yeah. Um,
yeah. I mean, I mean, Seymour
Hersh I think has walked
it back a little bit since,
but he said that in the early days.
Why do you think he believed it?
I read a really interesting article about
him just a few days ago. Where was it?
Um, I forget what it
was. It was, you know,
the expose any but a really good
look at, look at, look at him.
And I think he's just spent his career
believing rightly that the government
lies about all kinds of things.
And that's got me to a
point where he thinks will,
they always lie no matter what. Um, so,
and it's happened to a lot of journalists
that Robert Fisk, a Cmo Hush, um,
Martha Gellhorn during one of my
favorite war correspondents of all time.
I reread some of her stuff recently and
the first batch of war reporting she did,
I think is the best war reporting I've
ever read. Spanish civil war Vietnam.
Um, and then she spent 25 years writing
novels and then later on wrote about,
I believe it as the Yom Kippur war and
was denying that massacres that happened
and saying, you know,
Arabs lie, they always lie.
There was no massacre and we now know
there was a massacre or there were
massacres, um, in the aftermath
of these, of these wars. Um,
so I don't know what happened to me.
Maybe if you just do this for too long,
you just become so cynical that, that
you're open to these things, but it's,
yeah, I'm amazed at Seymour
Hersh is, is open to that idea
when the very people that are calling it,
the very people that have boots on the
ground that are in these war zones are
and calling these things, when they
become cynical and they become jaded,
that's when it gets really,
really sketchy.
And we rely so heavily on people like you.
Like there's, I'm not going
over there. You know what,
Jeremy's not going over there. We're
gonna. You know what I'm saying?
I mean in in and you wouldn't be able to
really get like I know people that gone
to Venezuela and they
come back and they go,
I don't know what the fuck is going on
over there. I don't know who to believe.
I don't understand it.
Venezuela is a very strange one and I
get messages all the time and you know
I've had Abby Martin who goes over there
and she has one take on it and I have
other people that I've talked to that
have a different take on it and I do not
know.
I don't know who to believe and I think
you'd have to go over there and do you
have to spend a lot of time to try to
figure this out and it would have to be
the entire focus of your life
to really try to Parse it out.
I think that's true of a lot of
conflicts. I mean, one of the, one of the,
one of the drawbacks of doing what I do
is I'm covering seven or eight things at
once.
So I feel like I'm not expert enough.
And even Afghanistan where I've covered,
I've covered that more than any other.
And, but the Venezuela is an
interesting one cause it's, there's,
there's such a left right divide on that.
And if you support the opposition,
then you find yourself alongside
John Bolton and Donald Trump,
which means that a lot of people are
gonna automatically attack you right
automatically. Even if it's
correct. And I think it's, you know,
we can say without a doubt the Maduro
has destroyed the economy there.
Maduro has imprisoned, beaten,
killed journalists. Um,
there is a movement there that
do want genuine elections. Um,
but some people will say,
well,
just because George Bush and another area
or John Beltland this era support the
opposition,
therefore the opposition
must be illegitimate and
the information coming out
must be,
must be false.
And I wish people did rely on,
on people who actually went there,
but it doesn't feel like that. It
feels like they rely on the, you know,
the guy behind the glass desk on the,
on the news when they were allowed
opinion rather where people are actually
there. While we still have
this idea, DNR had that. The,
the person who's reading the news is
the authority and the Don Lemon has the
inside scoop or whoever it is.
You know,
and I think it used to be that those
guys would spend 20 or 30 years traveling
and then that get the cushy job
behind the glass desk in the studio.
Now it seems like you can go straight
to the cushy job behind the glass desk.
Well,
did we just need someone who's relatable,
who can read a teleprompter,
you know,
who fits the profile that they're looking
for, whether it's Fox News or CNN,
you know, I know say the
information is there. You know,
there are fantastic documentaries,
articles being written about
all of these conflicts, right?
People aren't reading them
well with something like Venezuela that
the real problem is you have two sides.
You have two different versions of
what's happening, and it's, if you're,
if you're not educated in that country
and you don't understand their politics,
it's very difficult to figure out
who's telling the truth. Truth. Yep.
Same with Syria. Yeah. Yeah.